this is the Diamond Princess cruise
liner in February the ship became an
early flashpoint for the corona virus
outbreak passengers and crew were
quarantined as more than 700 of the
estimated 3700 people on board tested
positive for kovat 19 the now-infamous
ship is owned by Carnival the largest
cruise operator in the world
multiple cruise ships have experienced a
corona virus outbreak on board including
several owned by Carnival since the
corona virus outbreak hit the number of
cruise ships sailing around the world
has fallen drastically leaving the
cruise operator in a precarious position
but in the face of a pandemic health
authorities and passengers are
questioning whether cruise operators can
set sail safely going forward Carnival
began its history in 1972 as a cruise
liner with a single ship the Mardi Gras
up until then the industry was separated
small operators doing their own thing
Carnival was revolutionary because it
made cruising affordable to people from
every walks of life
Carnival fueled an industry-wide
shipbuilding boom in the 1980s and
branded itself as the world's most
popular cruise line the cruise operator
went public in 1987 and throughout the
next decade acquired or bought stakes
and several cruise lines amassing a
fleet of over 100 cruise ships today
they would compete directly with a
hospitality industry offering a
different product in throughout the past
two decades the company is whether
disease outbreaks we were told by our
infirmary
as well as natural disasters and
accidents at sea in 2012
the carnival operated Costa Concordia
ran aground in Italy the accident killed
32 people it was sinking so fast and
where we were standing is actually
underwater right now so obviously we
need to get off right then then in 2013
the company hired Arnold Donald to write
the ship as CEO under Donald carnival's
market value nearly doubled to forty
five billion dollars in 2017 he brought
them together in heavy a common strategy
of what they offer applying a way to
control costs across all those brands
over the past years the cruising
industry has been adding at least 1
million new passengers every year but in
2020 coronavirus became a major concern
for the cruise industry early on there
are two cruise ships had been
quarantined including the one right here
in Hong Kong behind me as well as one in
Yokohama Japan the fear is that chrono
virus is spreading carnaval and other
cruise operators begin canceling voyages
in Asia but as reports of virus
outbreaks aboard cruise ships like the
diamond princess kept spreading its
parent company largely continued full
steam ahead into March they were not
prepared for koruna virus because
nothing like this has hit them before
they could not evacuate thousands of
passengers they could not deal with a
rapidly spreading epidemic
the CDC declared a new sale order on
March 14th and carnival stock price has
fallen through the first few months of
the year to stay afloat the cruise
operator has been raising cash through
bond sales and has furloughed or laid
off employees and the company's sales
revenue is expected to drop
significantly in 2020 Carnival said it
plans to resume some sailings on August
1st despite a congressional inquiry into
the cruise operators health and safety
practices it's a matter of trust so it
will take a lot of convincing and a lot
of guarantees and above everything
sometime
for the clients to return and they're
counting the people's memories forum
Pleasant events is short with the corona
virus pandemic continuing what the
cruise industry looks like going forward
remains to be seen